those holidays off those break times um  those celebrations are because men and  women fought for those rights that we  have um to be able to celebrate this day  your family is protected by many laws  that pass you know like i talked about  the 40-hour work week you know you get  overtime you know we now have social  security there are the worker  protections so you know while we get to  enjoy this lovely day it's almost the  last day of summer so to speak um  understand that we get that because of  the hard work that the people have done  ahead of us  so enjoy but you guys the work's not  done  that's what i hear both the afl and sdiu  tell me there are a number of labor  rights concerns advocates are fighting  for today coming up i'll tell you more  about those concerns right now i'm live  outside of that ciu local chapter off of  west sahara and north rancho i'm kansas  charles it's newsnet